this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video where I'll be sharing a
special deal they're making available
through my channel now over to Grant
who's taking the reins for this one
while I'm on holiday
a simple definition of agility is our
body's ability to be fast and Nimble
change direction and change the
positioning of our body all while we
remain actively in motion agility is
also the ability to rapidly accelerate
or decelerate it's also influenced by
things like balance strength
coordination and skill level and in this
video we're going to be exploring these
traits my name is Grant Stevens and
welcome to this video about developing
agility and footwork within agility I
also like to consider things like
dexterity and Grace as a part of it as
well you can see when somebody has a
good command of their physical body by
how they perform tasks that are not
really related to their actual sport for
instance so things like how somebody
climbs the stairs this video is going to
focus on training athletic agility but I
don't think the importance of the trait
can be overstated a lack of agility and
movement in general is one of the
biggest contributing factors to aging
and people who've been relatively
sedentary their whole lives so we all
know like an elderly relative or
somebody that's taking a fall and didn't
have the strength and reactions in order
to prevent themselves from serious harm
and the sad thing about that is it
generally tends to be viewed as like
this is just what happens when you get
old and there's nothing that can be done
about it but I personally feel that
that's fundamentally false and the
deleterious effects of this can be
greatly mitigated by even just basic
training and self-maintenance so agility
can be improved by first developing an
adequate base of strength and
conditioning that is appropriate to the
skill level of the athlete when thinking
about this your mind will probably jump
to obvious examples in which agility
plays a role like parkour or football
for instance but having good agility is
a staple trait that will benefit you in
all areas of life and training for
example starting out bodybuilders might
feel like they don't need to do agility
training because it plays little
importance in gaining muscle which is
their main goal but they often tend to
come back to that later on once they've
been training a little bit because they
realize the importance of Maintenance in
that area now if they were to include
agility development into their training
it would make them more well-rounded and
could help things like maintaining
proper alignment and posture drawing
lifts which then translates to
increasing their gains besides that
agility training can help to protect
vulnerable areas such as the lower back
shoulders and ankles that are commonly
injured during training if you think
about somebody like an elite soldier
that requires a good balance of strength
power and endurance but also agility or
even the bioneer himself I'm Batman Adam
is a fine example of a good balance of
these traits he's incredibly strong and
powerful but I'm always pleasantly
surprised when we've done any sparring
together just how fast he is as well now
if I could only get him to just relax a
little bit more there's some overarching
principles in agility training as a
whole but then there will also be
specific requirements depending on the
activity that you choose for me and
martial arts there are obvious ones like
being able to shift my weight quickly
and I'll cover these in more detail
later including drills to develop them
but I've also found there's a vast array
of these kind of secondary benefits that
come as well which for me translates to
things like improving the actual
execution of the techniques themselves
which otherwise wouldn't become apparent
without good agility development this is
expressed in things like vanilla rotate
my body from a regular stance into a
turning kicking position rapidly
resulting in the whole technique taking
place over a much shorter duration and
then because of that increasing speed
also hits with greater force another
example might be in Striking with the
hands for instance now in boxing it's an
obvious trade that you need to be able
to move in and out of danger zones
effectively to evade your opponent's
strikes but also having good agility
will help you to be able to advance
forward quickly and if you're able to
shift your whole weight forward rapidly
you can then load your punches up on the
end of that movement to drastically
increase their power output so those
were just a few benefits that we can
gain from having good agility
development but now let's speak about
the fundamental traits that make up this
skill one of the first ones is
flexibility having a good degree of
flexibility is often an overlooked
factor of agility and if we have
tightness in certain muscles it will
Express itself as a hindered and stiff
looking movement which will slow us down
you don't need to be able to do the
splits or anything like that but
basically just ensure most of your
muscles are relatively loose and there
isn't any extreme inflexibility in any
of them good balance is also a necessary
foundation and even the most basic of
movements require at least some level of
balance and Agility to carry out with
the more complexity come in the harder
the movements are to perform balance is
a Paramount importance when being able
to remain upright and stable joint
movements and strengthen the core
muscles is a big contributing factor to
this you can train balance in many
different ways so pick something that
you basically get along with and I like
these types of exercises that are
similar to my own activity these combine
movement and deceleration to strengthen
the stabilization muscles and also
improve balance in a moment I'm going to
demonstrate some of the drills that I
like to personally use to develop
agility in my own training and give you
guys a little bit of a routine to follow
along with as well but before we do that
it's firstly important to speak about
the actual vehicle that's going to be
carrying out those movements which is
our physical body and it's kind of
General Physics that the lighter the
load that you have the easier it is
going to be to shift that around so if
you have some extra baggage then that's
obviously going to play a factor in
Hindi or movement now that's within
reason and I'm certainly not saying just
be as light as you can so if you're
underweight and severely lacking
muscular development to be even able to
move your body around effectively in the
first place and that's going to be
something to focus on first but the rule
generally applies I would say that you
want to kind of stick within a general
range of your natural weight so a little
bit below or a little bit above and if
you exceed that range too much on either
side then you're likely to see decreases
in your agility performance there
appears to be some outliers to this
people like Mike Tyson for instance but
on closer inspection the same rule
generally applies now Tyson fought is a
heavyweight but was considerably shorter
than the majority of his opponents but
he could move like he did at that size
because although he was big that still
wasn't that far out of his natural size
and this is some footage of him here at
15 years old believe it or not now
imagine if I decided to book up to the
size of Tyson while thinking I'd be able
to retain the agility I currently
possess even though he's about four or
so inches taller than me that would
require me gaining something like 60
extra pounds of weight in order to
achieve that weight class that he
thought is a heavyweight
now we're going to move on to the actual
agility training itself and I find the
best way to warm up for these types of
exercises is just to perform the same
ones or something very similar at a much
more relaxed and slower pace and then
when it comes to actually performing the
exercises at full speed the way that you
actually do these exercises is one of
the crucial factors that makes all the
difference so these work best when
they're done with intensity and with as
few pauses as possible by pauses I mean
the slight resetting of a person's
center of gravity during these movements
this can be seen in an exercise like the
Burpee in which less experienced people
will have to subtly reset their center
of gravity halfway through the movement
before completing the latter part making
it more like two separate exercises as
opposed to one fluid movement like this
when you become experienced in doing
exercises like this through many
repetitions over time they kind of take
on the dimension of being almost like a
skill in themselves and then obviously
that carries more knock-on benefits to
your athletic performance afterwards an
example of this in my domain is how the
set position before executing certain
kicking techniques is shortened so if
you imagine like in a video game when
you get a Reload upgrade to one of your
weapons it shortens the time that it
takes to reload that weapon this is kind
of similar to how it works with kicking
as well there's always a time where
someone transitions from moving around
to executing a kick and they have to
subtly reset their center of gravity the
better you are at doing this the less
time that set takes and obviously that
results in a more effective technique
the first thing I'm going to use here is
a jump rope in order to warm up for five
minutes or so so as you can see here I'm
just utilizing some basic movements at a
moderate pace and then building up as I
go one of the big things we jump rope
when many people go wrong is they jump
too high and it kills the momentum and
waste energy you should aim to almost
float in Rhythm and be very light on
your feet it should look as if you're
almost not trying
[Music]
[Applause]
next we're going to use the Agility
Ladder which is a great piece of
equipment and costs only about 15 again
this is going to start like a warm-up
activity and just Loosely going through
a set of movements you've chosen I'll do
around three to four rounds of these
building up intensity as I go and these
are some of the movement patterns I
often like to use with the latter it's
similar to jump rope in the fact that it
should look and feel kind of rhythmic
the way you progress in this type of
training is the process of incrementally
removing the time it takes to complete
each exercise or round and this is done
by making your movements as economical
as possible meaning that you're not
doing any more than you have to at each
stage any more than that and you're
losing energy and time
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
now we're going to move on to the main
portion of this utility workout the way
I like to do these is repeat the
exercise as many times as possible in a
30 second time period and I'll do about
three to four different exercises
repeating each one for 30 seconds and
then break for 30 seconds after those
now you can take a rest in between each
exercise or perform them all in
succession if you prefer I like to do
them in succession as it adds an element
of endurance in there as well so this
way I'm exposed to the stress of forcing
myself to remain light on my feet and
move quickly or while being under
increasing fatigue
so the first one I'm doing are these
side to side touchdowns now you want to
make sure that you're taking quite a few
steps in between the shuffle and I
almost try and turn sort of 180 degrees
in between each time I touch the floor
[Music]
on this next one I'm needling my feet
kind of like we do on the agility ladder
and then I'm moving into an in and out
position with the feet at a rapid Pace
when you do this try to make sure that
you're not using the upper body and all
the tension stays in the legs
[Music]
after that moving on to these full stamp
switches so as you can see here I'm
moving my body as one complete unit I'm
not twisting at the waist at all and I
keep my hands locked into my body to
make sure I'm isolating the leg muscles
I also like to do some 180 turnarounds
and I might even add a 360 in there as
well
lastly I'm just working on shifting
around some footwork and some turns and
I might even add a few punches in there
as well
[Music]
and as a bonus exercise you can do these
I'm not exactly sure what they're called
but they are very useful as well just
make sure that you're covering enough
distance to provide a good amount of
tension on that Landing leg
[Music]
I remember earlier when I said that the
way that you do these exercises is what
makes the difference and makes them work
and you'll know if you're doing this
effectively if they feel relatively
stressful upon the body so you should be
employing quite a significant amount of
force into the transition and Direction
changes in order to complete them
quickly if you're not doing this
efficiently then you're not keeping the
muscles and tendons under enough tension
throughout and they aren't going to
receive the sufficient stimulus to grow
the way this works during The Stance
switches for instance is in not stopping
between the switches by the time I feel
that point of Stillness as I land from
one switch I'm already engaging the
muscles once again to move in that
opposite direction when you start to get
tired during these just repeat the
movements at a slower Pace rather than
stopping in between where you're going
to lose the benefits many of the
elements in these drills I also include
into my martial arts movements in
general by doing this I'm training them
incidentally which is where it becomes
really interesting and a form of
self-expression that opens up many more
options for your own unique style you
can be really flexible with this and you
can incorporate anything from that
including the warm-up to make it the
main focus of your workout so instead of
The Stance drills like we did there been
the main focus you could make the ladder
drills the focus using more rounds and
variations of different exercises at
different speeds and so on you can be
really creative with it like anything to
improving these it's going to require
consistency and persistence and you
should aim to gradually improve over
time but you should definitely see some
improvements in your activity as knock
on benefits relatively quickly if you
start incorporating this training I'd
also suggest trying out new activities
as well like maybe dance or parkour or
something to expose yourself to new
movement patterns so if you enjoyed this
video and found something useful from it
that you can take and incorporate into
your own training in order to improve in
your agility as always please follow me
on social media I am now actually
uploading regular content to my YouTube
channel I know some people before were
saying that Adam was promoting my
Channel all the time and I hadn't
uploaded for ages which is not the case
anymore so follow there and I will see
you in the next video
so Squarespace is a website building
platform that's used by many of the top
brands on the web which is also
extremely simple and easy for anyone to
get started with in fact you can get a
website up and running within minutes
especially thanks to their new fluid
engine that makes the process as simple
as dragging and dropping the items where
you want them on the page you can start
from one of many ready-made templates
and then build on it from there to
create exactly the website you want but
beyond that you then have all the tools
you could need to run your entire
business from Squarespace blogging is
simple thanks to Advanced publishing
tools that allow you to format edit and
schedule posts for publishing later
their social media integration allowing
you to Simply and easily display your
social feeds on your website and allow
visitors to share the posts they enjoy
with their networks you can generate
Revenue through members-only gated
content you can manage your community
with threaded comments replies and likes
it can handle things like SEO and
e-commerce with ease thanks to many more
powerful tools and if you want to take
this even further then Squarespace
allows for the use of third-party
plugins that let you significantly
expand the capabilities of your website
for e-commerce for example you can add
things like sales tax reconciliation
global tracking inventory management and
much more if you want to learn more then
head over to squarespace.com and when
you're ready to take the plunge head to
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer to
get 10 off of your first domain or
website thanks so much for Squarespace
for sponsoring this video thanks to
grant for making it and thanks to you
guys for watching
bye for now